i've definitely learned some lessons
putting a just massive focus on people
first employees candidates clients i
didn't get my work-life balance right in
my old company and i think that it's
something i've really readdressed i'm
doing school pick up now twice a week
that flexibility for me is absolutely
game-changing you know i'm getting to
see my kids more and more quality time i
think you know previously i wasn't
majority shareholder of that business so
you know another lesson that i've
learned from myself is when you're not a
majority shareholder you kind of want
the business to not be able to run
without you and i think one of the
biggest lessons i learned was that i
want this new company to run without me
like you know if i take a holiday so i
just received a couple days off and i've
bought myself a burner phone with a
single number on my iphone's gone off
and if there's a tornado in the office
you can call that number if not i don't
want to hear from you and not only that
but the guys feel more empowered more
trusted because you know then trust us
then trust us to leave it alone just
trust your people like allow them to
make their own mistakes if you're
constantly in their stuff then it's just
not going to work
[Music]
you